how are ya pretty good Conan you're
doing great I don't know why I do what I
can for the kids yeah you're doing right
you're doing a lot of good stuff you got
this movie out Tommy Boy just doing
great and you were you were down in
Washington this thing got a lot of press
you're down in Washington you went you
did your Newt Gingrich you dressed up as
Newt Gingrich and you were you were to
do it like you went with the Republicans
is that right yeah they're in Republican
Congress and Newt Gingrich was there he
was all surprised because he didn't know
we were doing it I guess some of his
yeah right right
this was really they you you went in
there as Newt Gingrich and this is what
we have a clip of it I think it speaks
for itself Dana roll this clip of Chris
Farley as Newt Gingrich wreaking havoc
in Washington okay first up HR 765 which
would cut taxes for the middle class
lower the deficit in the same time all
in favor I can't hear you all right also
a motion that tax cut bill doesn't have
to go through Senate all in favor all
right
all opposed you know what I don't care
you don't get to vote all right let's
keep moving we got nine minutes left
HR four three three which would make
Senator Mark Hatfield officially a
Democrat all in favor
[Applause]
HR 963 motion that from now on all
Democrats are officially weird
all in favor okay let's go let's go
let's go we're burning daylight okay HR
eight three two to keep reporters away
from my mother what do you say how about
even though he had nothing to do with it
would take credit friend in the baseball
strike
I think you like did you get to talk to
Gingrich at all yeah hey he came back
and you know he he was glad that I did
it I think yeah tensioner whatever he
liked a good time what do you think he
actually he got the I guess he got the
tax cuts through the other day do you
think they're actually gonna want to
pass in the Senate you think it has a
chance have you awesome he said that
might go for it I mean cuz if that
passes you know you you know he's really
fulfilled a big chunk of his uh you know
contract with america first hundred days
don't you think yeah he was really cool
great guys one going down there mmm-hmm
and then yeah do do you think Newt
Gingrich is gonna make it you think he's
gonna do a good job you know a speaker I
think he's gonna go all the way Conan
I'm not much of a reader you know they
get me they put a wig on me
I don't know
[Applause]
I'm sorry America I owe you an apology
David Mandel is one of the writers he
wrote the whole damn thing apart me I
wouldn't know a political agenda if it
came up and bit me and no famiiy
[Applause]
come on now come on it's not no you're
not Chris you're not a fool you must you
must know something come on
well I'll give it a shot to give you any
question from history and I I prove to
you I'm a more oh come on you know you
know like you must know about you know
the Civil War which one Chris come on
it's not that bad things are going your
way you should be happy
yeah you're a clown but you're a very
successful clown come on feel good about
yourself you know you got this movie out
you're out impressing people in Kearney
but your life must be changing right now
you must be must be getting a lot of
nice attention chicks OC from chicks
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there you go you're doing well with the
ladies right now I would think you are
got a new suit from the big and tall
shot yeah you're doing that you seen
anyone in particular right now I'm no
stranger to the gals I'll tell you that
and no I'm not seeing anyone per se it
gets kind of lonely on the road but we
just we just said right now the audience
went crazy the girls in the audience
went crazy when we announced that you'd
do well with the ladies come on you
could you could really score
[Applause]
are you doing you sure are Purdy
my name's Chris Farley from Mauritania
boy maybe
it seems to be kind of a natural you and
I
[Applause]
I know your Tommy boys but to use
someone enter the snow what you think I
do it all these Hot Tamales remember
this Chris
I saw the skin stains in your underwear
[Applause]
I'm sorry
[Applause]
I feel bad okay that's an awkward moment
Castle Chris we're just gonna get over
that nasty little incident folks we'll
have more with Chris Farley when we come
back we'll take a quick break
[Applause]